To get a sense of how involved it would be to track all the photons in a scene,
I want you to do a rough estimate. Say we have ten 40 watt light bulbs in a
room. As mentioned before, each produces 10 to the 19th photons per second.
About a billion computers, 10 to the 9th are currently in use world wide. Say
each computer can trace a million photons through a scene per second. This is an
unrealistically high rate, since we're talking about tracing each photon until
it is absorbed by an object or it reaches the camera. Your grandmother's
computer likely can not do this. So, the question to you is how many earth's
worth of computers would we need to trace all the photons in a scene in real
time and so form an image? So, your choices are, we need just one earth's worth,
ten earth's worth, one hundred earth's worth or ten million earth's worth of
computers to do this in real time.